this question has over 40 000 likes on
Reddit and many news organizations are
covering the problem
Klein read 30 pages of a book on Monday
and 1 8 of the book on Tuesday he
completed the remaining one-fourth of
the book on Wednesday how many pages are
there in the book in the Old way to
solve it we would let X be the number of
pages in the book we then have the
equation 30 plus X over 8 plus X over 4
is equal to X we now just carefully
simplify this equation and we solve that
X is equal to 48 pages
but there's a new way students solve
this problem we have a bar of 30 pages
now divide the entire book into eight
parts and we've read one of the eight
parts divide the book into four parts
and we've read one of the four parts add
these parts together so we've read three
of the eight parts and that means 30 is
equal to five of the eight parts so that
means each of these will be equal to 30
divided by 5 which is equal to six then
we need eight total Parts multiplying
six by eight we get 48 pages